hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master bones yeah Franco let's go
you replace mc5 stuff the ad g 3g sixes
that's what he usually does I can't go
here and now yeah I'm not really you
should expert them at let's go with a
3mm should be 71 for the fire play with
g3 now can I switch to that approach I
know normally if always played but i can
try this alright still place this one
okay I just got I don't know is this
interesting in this Bishop e7 and a3 now
in as additional moves compared to the
direct g3 line
[Music]
I wonder to decide really work I mean
there are those ideas to sacrifice the
d5 pawn back is this one of them doesn't
feel like it
I mean why can I don't take here before
I is covered now okay so it's just a
born let's do a take on Bishop g2 I
think I'll take two it's got Bishop f6
but it can never be enough for four
healthy pawn so I don't like to go back
but probably have to
is it some compensation I mean no 95 95
is good the bishop has nowhere to go if
I'm getting this Bishop I'm completely
fine okay even Bishop see one is okay
and then one day I have to play that
move would like to avoid it of course
but it's probably impossible
it's still some pressure
yeah I'm I'm just completely I'm
switching now to killing this Bishop I
know that looks a bit sick to block my
own diagonal but this is a dead piece
and this is worth a lot you're basically
playing playing against them you can
kill off a whole piece this is this is
really a extremely helpful if I go F for
he will sacrifice so I shouldn't do that
still has some activity of course oh
come on notnot some no numerical moves
please yeah this book this works now
fantastic ok I have the better ending in
some ways the better ending Bishop I
Bishop g2 bishops III is better for
white and there Corsican Teague ik me
let's do this ending now at least then I
have a completely risk-free fully
advantage that might or might not win
gasps still it's sick should have gotten
more him
you
you
okay well I can retake see itk for so
high morning can also check him just
wait wait a moment him so bit difficult
to make any headway oh come on I'll take
this check
king size structure is actually quite
favorable yeah so i can i can try to get
to the edge pawn also can run up to f6
which is pretty nice check
check check got no time that's a problem
of course position is sighs relatively
easy win check check check check
black resigns it's a nice of him I don't
know if I've managed in seven seconds um
yeah probably but not easy okay so let's
let's have a look down I was still a bit
sick that it got so wet it got so
difficult I think md5 years is basically
blunder her blunder I don't I don't see
this being a correct pawn sacrifice
would default did not see this idea this
is move okay then this okay it's not
something that occurs naturally to you
and play I guess but I kind of get it
that that could be compensation okay and
after this i'm just a pawn up because of
the fork tricks there are cases where
black can't sack this pawn but then he
has Bishop before as a key move which is
not available here so here yeah this is
the key that I get this Bishop Jen okay
the engine with wants to play actively
it's probably better it's probably
better at turn yeah and now i just
switched to killing this this piece I
mean I think this cannot be bad really I
mean he's playing a bishop down him he's
very active of course but ok bishop age
six and then f3 okay this yeah maybe I
should have taken I did not want to take
this one now yeah the rook ending is
very good for why this is why I way I
played Edward amazing age five
supposed to be okay really I mean this
looks terrible again it's a bishop down
but maybe yeah maybe he is active enough
and somehow get my stuff not coordinated
I mean it's important to see any ending
like when I trade one rookie or
something he can just resign because
this Bishop is it's not ever moving it's
a dead piece I threaten f4 f5 in the
long run and he plays a bishop down so
the only thing is that he's very active
of course and maybe he can this be he is
so active that I cannot convert let's
say the the somewhat extra piece it's
hard to believe yeah ok now the rook
ending is of course it's clearly better
for white is it winning hmm yeah maybe
maybe maybe it is which it's not the
same it took it yeah I think it must be
very good year the edge porn this is
very helpful yeah to to get this [ __ ] to
space him yet can I think I played it ok
was maybe a bit I could have played it
quicker maybe with purely the moves I
think were OK in ending ok guys thanks
for watching